what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to Blind first dates this
one is titled revealing you're pregnant
on a first date because modern women
just have the audacity I guess but
anyways we'll see how this goes um like
the video on your way and subscribe to
the channel because my goal is to get to
a million before New Year's and that's a
hefty goal that's a lofty goal but I
think we can do it so subscribe to the
channel
thank you
cheers
it's like an army theme Army half the
buck is like a open field oh he's
handsome he's a handsome man like a puff
going through it and then there's an
angel on top of stairs yeah and then a
couple other puppies are like initials
are friends
[Music]
you're in the army
I'm not cool
really wow
wow okay um how long have you been out
I've been out five years you'll see you
in the minutes yeah yeah my sister was
really yeah
I heard that there's a negative
stereotype around Army girls or um girls
that are in the military I've heard this
that a lot of girls in the military are
304s I didn't know about this because I
don't know much about the military but
this is a new thing that I've heard
sometimes
you got any kids and no okay I'd like to
yeah I've got to the age where I'm
thinking oh no she's thinking oh he'd
like to oh no it's not gonna happen you
sort of think how am I getting too old
now I think it's more of her maybe the
time I think yeah but I think I'll be a
great father
if I was with somebody
um
children
be an option
so children
[Music]
ever married
and I was married when I was younger
okay divorced at 26.
and I've got a baby on the way now
why would they do this to this man this
is a man who wants to be a dad he's a
he's handsome like that is a handsome
man he's handsome he wants to be a dad
he yeah I'm like what the [__] put me on
one of these blind dates God damn you're
gonna set him up with a pregnant girl
getting no system six months pregnant
now six months okay it's a donor baby
so I've got no crazy acts and rounds
street corners fighting for custody a
donor baby yo women that do that are
selfish and I stand by this they're so
concerned about what they want they
can't just like level go to their level
and date the guys that are on their
level they're like you know what
I'm gonna women that that choose to be
single mothers are selfish I like that
so
[Music]
good for you good for you
whatever's gonna be there and I'll
embrace it off because I embrace life
generally anyway
it speaks a lot about you for doing it
anyway oh thank you okay do you see the
body language like he's leaning in and
she's not he's assume
um
why why do you guys look at it's like
sometimes I love y'all but sometimes
y'all create these modern women this he
should have said Haram and ended the
date that's what he should have did
Haram Haram but he said good for you
like we are lied to constantly stop
lying to us yeah thanks
so I like Jackson James sort of boy and
I like Remy for a girl yeah
I'm interested now
the cartoon
is it oh no it's a rat
oh I have to think of another girls
trying to get my head round over there
yeah but yeah
so I've been married with a guy and I've
dated women after that my last
relationship red black
guys that is a red flat I'm sorry that's
a red flag she was so traumatized by men
that she dated women that speaks about
her choice in men don't let her play you
oh my God he's going for it too
I'm curious now have you thought I want
to be with a man I think being with a
guy is simple is it really is is that's
a surprise
he was a gentleman I picked that up in
in his conversations and the way he
embraced um me and my story and what
I've came with because women generally
get more attached as friends anyway in
the beginning I thought it was easier
and it was really nice because women
bonded together really quickly and it's
quite intense and all that's lovely but
the breakup side of it it's worse yeah
it is worse because you kind of losing a
best friend's and a partner at the same
time I'm trying to see her belly I like
don't even see it there's a lot of
connections there just by our
backgrounds our army family and my
experiences we're going to be able to
talk about that
please telling me he's doing this for
the TV run okay I'm sorry this girl's
gotta sleep full of tattoos
um she's got a donor to have a child
she's been married before
um
[Music]
and she's pregnant she's pregnant
so would you guys like to see each other
romantically again
I I would like to see you again thank
you very much thank you all right
instantly yes oh
I'm speech
I can't even feel bad for you guys
anymore I can't even feel bad for like
the video
please as as a payment for making me
watch this atrocity like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
bring that notification Bell bye as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible